for physical things because Google is
I.T then yeah I think Blue Collar
halfway through this year if it's a real
recession I think we should be seeing
some of that and I don't look forward to
it it's going to hurt core America I'll
add to that Tom you know likes to give
them more macro perspective I'll give
more the micro perspective how that
affects you as your life well I'm going
to channel my inner Warren Buffett you
know the one way to be Recession Proof
or inflation proof is to be the best at
your job so we talked about which
teachers should get raises and which
teachers should be fired and you think
that you should fire the bottom 10 20
there's no question about it no question
yeah so if you suck at your job you're
probably gonna get fired but if you're
great at your job you're probably going
to keep your job you're probably going
to get a raise and God forbid your
company has layoffs this is going to be
a job waiting for you so at the end of
the day it comes down to personal
responsibility personal accountability
personal finance if you're the [ __ ] at
your job not shitty at your job you're
gonna have a job forever yeah if you
suck good rid